Ja, das Ende vom Corona-Sommer ist
spannend.
Die Infektionszahlen steigen langsam,
tausende demonstrieren
gegen Corona-Maßnahmen,
Urlaubsrückkehrer bringen
frisches Virus mit nach Hause,
das unbemerkt, nachdem es in Bayern
die große Testpanne gab.
Kaum sind die ersten Schulen
wieder auf,
wurden die ersten wieder geschlossen.
Das ist alles nicht so toll.
Aber meanwhile: In den USA
könnte die Zahl der Todesopfer ...
Mehr als 100.000 Menschen ...
Indien verzeichnet zwei Millionen ...
Israel droht der zweite Lockdown ...
Der Blick ins Ausland
zeigt zwei Dinge:
Erstens: Wir haben in Deutschland
offenbar vieles richtig gemacht.
Zweitens: Das, was wir
bisher erlebt haben,
an Todesfällen, Lockdown-Schäden,
ist noch lange nicht alles,
was dieses ver*** Virus kann.
Wir stehen also
gerade an einem Punkt der Pandemie,
an dem das alte
deutsche Sprichwort gilt:
"Lass und keine Panik schieben,
aber auch bitte nicht verkacken."
Ein gutes altes Sprichwort.
Wie schaffen wir es, nicht
in die Pandemie zurückzurutschen?
Darum geht es in diesem Video.
Ich verspreche euch, im Gegensatz
zum letzten Corona-Video,
endet dieses hier
wirklich hoffnungsvoll.
Denn es gibt neue Tests,
die unser komplettes Leben
auf den Kopf, also ...
positiv auf den Kopf ...
auf die Füße? Ihr wisst schon.
Die alles verändern könnten.
Stellt euch vor:
Bevor Kinder in die Schule gehen,
spucken sie auf einen Test,
und Kinder mit positivem Ergebnis
werden nach Hause geschickt.
Aber eins nach dem anderen,
holt euch 'nen Tee.
Macht es euch gemütlich,
wir steigen durch.
(Dynamische Musik)
Was ist momentan eigentlich
der Corona-Masterplan?
Wir sollten
Superspreading Events vermeiden,
wie feiernde Menschen
in geschlossenen Räumen.
Aber auch Containment,
Eindämmung, ist wichtig.
Also: Infektionen erkennen
und Infektionsketten unterbrechen.
In der Praxis:
testen und Kontakte verfolgen.
Dann kann man strenge
Schutzmaßnahmen, wie Quarantäne,
auf infizierte Personen
und deren Kontakte beschränken,
während für den Rest gilt:
"Keep calm and carry on."
Das ist der Witz
von Containment.
Wir schützen unsere Gesundheit
und Mitmenschen,
und stellen sicher,
dass das öffentliche Leben
nicht lahmgelegt wird.
Also, Containment: gut.
Die Kapazitäten, um Kontakte
zu verfolgen und zu testen,
sind begrenzt.
Wenn wir das sprengen,
die Behörden nicht hinterherkommen,
weil die Infektionszahlen zu hoch
sind oder zu schnell steigen,
kommen wir dahin,
wo wir im Frühjahr waren,
dass wir strenge Maßnahmen für alle
einführen müssen oder Lockdowns.
Und seien es erst nur Lokale,
das wollen wir nicht.
Containment-Kapazitäten sprengen:
Nicht gut.
Was tun wir also,
um unsere Containment-Kapazitäten
nicht zu sprengen?
Na ja, grundsätzlich
gibt es ja zwei Stellschrauben:
Reden wir über die Infektionen.
Die Infektionszahlen
steigen gerade wieder langsam.
Das liegt nicht nur daran,
dass wir mehr testen.
Meine Kollegen von "Quarks"
haben das visualisiert.
Hier der Anteil positiver Tests
im Verhältnis zur Gesamttestmenge.
Dieser Peak,
das war der Tönnies-Ausbruch.
Dann geht's runter, aber seit
'ner Weile steigen die Zahlen
langsam aber stetig.
Ist das ein Grund zur Panik?
Nein.
Denn auch wenn
die absoluten Infektionszahlen
ähnlich hoch sind wie im März,
als die Schulen
geschlossen wurden,
steigen die Infektionszahlen
gerade deutlich langsamer.
Aber vor allem wegen
der Superspreading Events,
gibt es keine Garantie,
dass das so bleibt.
Paar Superspreading Events
und es geht wieder ab.
Außerdem kommen
noch Herbst und Winter,
wir sind bald
nicht mehr so viel draußen,
wo das Infektionsrisiko geringer ist.
Deswegen dürfen wir nicht
in 'ne Spirale rutschen,
nach dem Motto: "Sind die Kitas
offen, kann ich ins Büro.
Bin ich im Büro,
kann ich Fußballspielen.
Dann kann ich zum Konzert gehen."
Nein!
Alles was vermeidbar ist,
sollte auch vermieden werden.
Denn jede vermiedene Infektion hilft.
Gleichzeitig können wir
nicht alles vermeiden.
Das öffentliche Leben
muss weitergehen,
die Schulen und Kitas müssen öffnen,
weil die Schäden der Schließung
nicht mehr tragbar sind.
Deswegen müssen wir gleichzeitig
unsere Containment-Maßnahmen boosten.
Hier ist viel passiert,
es gibt mehr Tests,
die Corona-Warn-App,
für die Kontaktverfolgung.
Wenn ihr die noch nicht habt,
installiert sie.
Es gibt Containment Scouts,
um die Gesundheitsämter zu entlasten.
Die Kontaktdaten im Restaurant zu
hinterlassen, ist auch Containment.
In dem Video wollen wir
den Fokus auf die Tests legen
und die Frage:
Wie können wir mehr testen?
Schöpfen wir gerade
alle denkbaren Testkapazitäten aus?
Gehen wir das mal durch:
Erst mal kurz:
Das Grundprinzip der Labortechnik,
weil das später noch wichtig wird,
der Corona-Test, der Standard-Test,
ob man gerade infiziert ist,
ist ein sogenannter:
Manchmal sagt man auch nur PCR-Test.
RT-PCR steht für:
Und beschreibt eine Labortechnik,
in der man Viren-RNA
isoliert, die in DNA umwandelt,
und dann Teile dieser DNA vermehrt,
bis das Ganze sichtbar,
also detektierbar, wird.
Das Gute an den PCR-Tests:
sie sind verlässlich,
und auch kleine Viruskonzentrationen
können noch gut nachgewiesen werden.
Das Schlechte ist,
dass diese PCR-Tests
dem eigentlichen,
tatsächlichen Infektionsgeschehen
immer 'n bisschen hinterherhinken.
Denn inzwischen wissen wir,
dass man am ansteckendsten ist,
kurz bevor man Symptome bekommt.
Weil ich mich erst testen lasse,
wenn ich Symptome habe,
hab ich bis dahin
vielleicht andere angesteckt.
Corona kann auch mild,
oder sogar asymptomatisch verlaufen,
sodass solche Leute
gar nicht getestet werden,
obwohl sie andere anstecken können.
Eigentlich müsste man also viel
großflächiger und häufiger testen.
Präventiv testen, vorbeugend, nicht
erst, wenn's schon passiert ist.
Teilweise wird das gemacht,
in Krankenhäusern,
wenn man stationär aufgenommen wird,
wird man erst getestet.
Auch bei Pflegeheimen hat sich
Gesundheitsminister Jens Spahn
für präventive
Reihentests ausgesprochen.
Doch in der Praxis
werden die kaum gemacht.
Und bei Schulen und Kitas,
da präventiv zu testen,
das ist utopisch,
das würde die Kapazitäten sprengen
und wäre zu teuer.
Also, PCR-Tests
verlässlich aber teuer und langsam.
Ich benutze so viel Daumen
in dem Video.
Aber was ist mit:
Die beruhen
auf 'ner anderen Labortechnik,
wo nicht das Virus selbst
nachgewiesen wird,
sondern ob man Antikörper
gegen das Virus im Blut hat.
Antikörpertests
gibt's überall zu kaufen.
Darunter Schnelltests, die in zehn
Minuten das Ergebnis zeigen sollen.
Antikörper im Blut werden oft
als Immunitätsnachweis verstanden.
Es wäre eine riesige Erleichterung,
zu wissen,
wenn man immun wäre, sich selbst und
andere nicht mehr anstecken könnte.
Und eine langfristige Erleichterung
wäre das,
im Gegensatz
zu 'nem negativen Virustest,
der nur sagt, dass ich
aktuell nicht infiziert bin.
Könnte man nicht wenigstens
großflächig
Antikörpertests durchführen?
Schließlich wär's
sehr wertvoll zu wissen,
ob jemand
in systemrelevanten Einrichtungen,
wie Krankenhäusern, immun ist.
Das Problem ist,
dass Antikörpertests
für die allgemeine Bevölkerung
nicht genau genug sind.
Und warum sie nicht genau genug sind,
das müssen wir verstehen,
auch wenn sich manche denken:
"Boah, wann kommt die Alte
zum hoffnungsvollen Teil?"
Ihr seht die Kapitel,
ihr könnt es überspringen.
Tut es nicht! Denn wir können
nur beurteilen, wie sinnig
oder unsinnig ein Test ist,
wenn wir bisschen
Teststatistik verstehen.
Und genau diese Teststatistik
wird immer wieder
von Verschwörungstheoretikern
falsch dargestellt.
Die kommen damit nur durch, weil sich
nicht genug Leute damit auskennen.
Also, seid ihr am Start?
(off:) Yay, Statistik.
Buh, Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Kein Test ist perfekt.
Es wird immer
falsche Ergebnisse geben,
aber es macht bei einem falschen Test
einen wichtigen Unterschied,
auf welche Art er falsch ist.
Es gibt zwei mögliche Fehler.
Entweder ist er
fälschlicherweise positiv.
Ich hab einen künstlich-intelligenten
Hut-Detektor entwickelt.
Das Ergebnis ist:
Du hast 'nen Hut auf.
Okay.
Oder das Ergebnis ist
fälschlicherweise negativ.
Moment, der Hut-Detektor sagt:
Du hast keinen Hut auf.
Alter.
Beide Fehler sind doof,
aber unterschiedlich doof.
Wenn ich einen falsch-positiven
Virustest bekomme,
müsste ich unnötig in Quarantäne.
Doof. Aber bei einem
falsch-negativen Test,
wiege ich mich
in falscher Sicherheit,
und stecke vielleicht jemanden an,
für den Corona lebensbedrohlich ist.
Verdammt doof. Bei 'nem
Antikörpertest wär's andersrum.
Ein falsch-positiver Test führt
zu falscher Sicherheit, langfristig.
Da es in der Praxis wichtig ist,
diese Fehler zu unterscheiden,
gibt es in der Wissenschaft
zwei verschieden Größen. Erstens:
Zweitens:
Beides wird in Prozent angegeben.
Zum Beispiel:
Dann bedeutet das,
dass unter den Nichtinfizierten,
95 Prozent ein korrekt-negatives
Ergebnis bekommen,
fünf Prozent aber
ein falsch-positives.
So weit, so einfach. Das Wichtige,
das viele missverstehen:
Wenn ich bei einem 95 Prozent
spezifischen Test
ein positives Ergebnis bekomme,
heißt das wohlgemerkt nicht,
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass dieses Ergebnis korrekt ist,
95 Prozent beträgt.
Sie könnte auch nur 50 Prozent
betragen. Klingt komisch, is aber so.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich
mit 'nem positiven Testergebnis
auch tatsächlich
infiziert bin, nennt sich:
Diese prädiktiven Werte, PPW und NPW,
hängen nicht nur von der Spezifität
und der Sensitivität der Tests ab,
sondern auch von der Häufigkeit
der Krankheit, von der Prävalenz.
Klingt komisch, is so. Der
Hut-Detektor is gut oder schlecht,
das sollte nicht davon abhängen,
wie viele Hutträgerinnen es gibt.
Doch, ihr werdet sehen, warum.
Es gibt bei einem Test vier Gruppen:
A: Die Anzahl der Leute,
die korrekt positiv getestet werden.
B: Die Leute,
die falsch positiv getestet werden.
C: Die Leute,
die falsch negativ getestet werden.
Und D: Die Leute,
die korrekt negativ getestet werden.
Der Positiv Prädiktive Wert
ist die Anzahl
der korrekt positiven Tests
geteilt durch die Anzahl
aller positiven Testes.
Der Negativ Prädiktive Wert
ist die Anzahl der
korrekt negativen Testergebnisse
geteilt durch
alle negativen Ergebnisse.
veranschaulichen wir das
an einem konkreten Beispiel
für einen Antikörpertest.
Wir gehen aus von einer Prävalenz,
Häufigkeit, von einem Prozent.
Ein Prozent der Bevölkerung
hat tatsächlich Antikörper
gegen Corona im Blut.
Wir haben einen Antikörpertest mit
einer Sensitivität von 94 Prozent
und einer Spezifität von 99 Prozent.
Realistische Annahmen
laut diesem Artikel, wo mehr
Szenarien durchgerechnet werden.
Sagen wir, wir testen eine
repräsentative Bevölkerungsgruppe
von 10.000 Menschen.
Ein Prozent Prävalenz heißt,
hundert haben Antikörper,
die restlichen 9.900 nicht.
Die Testsensitivität
ist 94 Prozent, heißt:
von den hundert Leuten
mit Antikörpern
werden 94 Prozent, sprich 94 Leute,
korrekt positiv getestet.
bei sechs liefert der Test
ein falsch-negatives Ergebnis.
Sprich: A ist 94, und C ist sechs.
Unter den 9.900 Menschen
ohne Antikörper
werden mit einer Testspezifität
von 99 Prozent
99 Prozent der Leute, also 9801
Leute, korrekt negativ getestet.
Die restlichen ein Prozent,
also 99 Leute,
kriegen ein
falsch-positives Ergebnis.
D ist 9801 und B ist 99.
Wenn ich jetzt bei dieser Messung
ein positives Ergebnis erhalte,
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich
tatsächlich Antikörper im Blut habe,
gerade mal 48,7 Prozent.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
ist fifty-fifty.
Dabei klingt
eine Sensitivität von 94 Prozent
und eine Spezifität
von 99 Prozent irreführend hoch.
Wenn ich allerdings
ein negatives Ergebnis erhalte,
dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass das stimmt: 99,9 Prozent.
Ein negatives Testergebnis
ist fast sicher richtig,
ein positives Testergebnis hingegen
gar nicht sicher.
Genau das ist auch
tatsächlich das Problem
mit Antikörpertests.
Die Prävalenz der Krankheit
fließt stark in diese Formeln ein.
Testet man mit dem gleichen Test
Risikogruppen,
wo die Prävalenz höher ist,
ist auch der PPW höher.
Aber für die allgemeine Bevölkerung
ist ein positives Testergebnis
deutlich weniger verlässlich
als ein negatives.
Für alle Tests gilt,
nicht nur für Antikörpertests,
je seltener eine Krankheit ist,
desto mehr
falsch-positive Ergebnisse gibt es.
Nun kann man dieses Problem
aber abfangen,
und zwar mit einer
richtig hohen Spezifität.
Würden wir in unserem Beispiel
einen Test nehmen
mit einer Spezifität von 99,9 Prozent
statt nur 99 Prozent,
dann steigt
der Positiv Prädiktive Wert
von knapp 50 Prozent auf 90 Prozent.
Die PCR-Tests,
also die normalen Virustests,
haben eine sehr hohe Spezifität.
Denn damit ist es nicht ungewöhnlich,
dass man auf eine Spezifität
von 100 Prozent kommt.
So 'n Test funktioniert
auch bei kleiner Prävalenz.
Es sei denn, man verkackt es,
indem man den Rachenabstrich
falsch macht,
was zu 'nem falsch-negativen
Ergebnis führt. Oder:
True Story aus den USA,
zu falsch positiven Ergebnissen.
Bei der Amerikanischen
Gesundheitsbehörde
wurde eine Komponente
der PCR-Testkits
im gleichen Raum hergestellt,
wo echte Proben des Virus waren.
Anscheinend ist dabei Virus
in einige der Testkits gelangt,
sodass manche Tests von vornherein
positiv waren. Upsi.
Wenn das nicht passiert,
können wir uns auf die Ergebnisse
der PCR-Tests verlassen.
Falls ihr im Internet
über Zahlen stolpert,
die behaupten, wir hätten
nicht so viele Infizierte,
das seien alles nur
falsch-positive Tests,
dann checkt noch mal
ganz genau deren Quellen.
Falls sie überhaupt welche
zum Nachprüfen verlinken.
Unsere Quellen sind wie immer
unten in der Videobeschreibung. Okay.
Statistik ist damit abgehakt.
Wir sind bereit
für die guten Nachrichten.
Wir haben gerade gelernt,
ein Corona-Test, der ungenau ist,
bringt nichts. Und jetzt will ich
euch genau das Gegenteil erzählen.
Plot Twist. Okay passt auf,
es gibt immer mehr
Stimmen aus der Forschung,
die sich
für Corona-Schnelltests einsetzen,
die eine ziemlich schlechte
Sensitivität haben.
Eine ziemlich hohe
falsch-negativ Rate.
Es gibt einen
Labor-Schnelltest für Corona,
den sogenannten ID Now Test,
der in Minuten ausgewertet ist.
Aber eine Sensitivität
von gerade mal 52 Prozent besitzt.
Nach dem, was wir besprochen haben,
ist das zu wenig,
man hat direkt gesagt: "Weg damit."
Die medizinische Zulassungsbehörde
in den USA hat für diesen Test
eine Warnung veröffentlicht,
über die hohe Gefahr von
falsch-negativen Ergebnissen. Aber:
Diese 52 Prozent sind nicht etwa
zufällig verteilt,
sondern der Test wird
vor allem dann falsch-negativ,
wenn die Viruskonzentration,
also die Viruslast,
unter einen bestimmten Wert fällt.
Proben mit geringer Viruslast
werden mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
falsch-negativ gemessen,
aber Proben mit hoher Viruslast
werden mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
korrekt positiv-gemessen.
In der Studie
hat man das genauer angeschaut.
Hier seht ihr eine logarithmische
Auftragung der Viruslast
im Verlauf der Krankheit.
Sie steigt anfangs sehr schnell an,
und fällt dann langsam wieder ab.
Die untere, pinke Linie, ist
das Detektionslimit der PCR-Tests.
LOD steht für "Level Of Detection".
Die obere, violette Linie, das ist
das Testlimit solcher Schnelltests.
Der springende Punkt ist,
dass man um so ansteckender ist,
je höher die Viruslast ist.
Das führt uns zu einer
ziemlich attraktiven Überlegung.
Nämlich, dass diese
sehr wenig sensitiven Tests,
die aber schneller, einfacher,
günstiger sind als PCR-Tests,
und deswegen auch viel häufiger
eingesetzt werden könnten,
dass die ausreichen,
um Menschen mit hoher Viruslast
also Personen, von denen auch
ein hohes Ansteckungsrisiko ausgeht,
dass man die verlässlich
erkennen kann.
Die Personen,
die der Test nicht erkennen kann,
sind ohnehin diejenigen
mit geringer Viruslast,
von denen auch ein entsprechend
geringeres Ansteckungsrisiko ausgeht.
Es gibt sogar Schnelltests,
für die man kein Labor braucht.
Wie diese
Schwangerschaftstest-artigen Tests.
Man spuckt quasi
auf einen Teststreifen,
kurz später
wird das Ergebnis angezeigt.
Diese Papierstreifen
sind mit Antikörpern versehen,
die auf bestimmte Teile
des Virus reagieren,
auf die Antigene des Virus.
Diese Antigen-Tests
sind so günstig herzustellen,
dass man einen Streifen für ein,
zwei Dollar verkaufen könnte.
Versteht ihr, was so günstige
und so einfache Tests
für 'n Game Changer sein könnten?
Stellt euch vor:
Bevor Kinder in die Schule gehen,
spucken sie auf einen Test,
ist er positiv,
gehen sie direkt nach Hause.
Grobe aber häufige Schnelltests
könnten an allen Stellen
zum Einsatz kommen,
wo PCR-Tests zu langsam
oder teuer sind.
Zum Beispiel fängt ja bald
die Erkältungssaison an.
Viele werden ständig
Corona-ähnliche Symptome haben,
aber nicht alle
werden 'n PCR-Test bekommen,
darunter auch die Kita-Kinder,
die ohnehin ständig rumhusten.
Sagen wir, es gibt
'nen Fall in der Schule.
Man könnte an dieser Schule über
einen gewissen Zeitraum täglich
alle durchtesten, um hochinfektiöse
Personen sofort rauszuziehen.
Oder man könnte durch Schnelltests
Quarantänezeiten verkürzen.
Viele Anwendungsgebiete
sind denkbar.
Natürlich sollten
solche Quick-and-Dirty-Tests
nicht die genauen PCR-Tests ersetzen,
aber ergänzen.
Wenn man Leute an ihren
ansteckendsten Tagen
erwischen könnte,
könnte man neue Ausbrüche
im Keim ersticken.
Also, Schnelltests,
selbst mit niedriger Sensitivität,
könnten genau die Zusatzmaßnahme
sein, die es braucht,
dass wir im Herbst und Winter
ein halbwegs normales
öffentliches Leben führen können,
ohne eine zweite Welle zu riskieren.
Also, mich stimmt das alles
sehr hoffnungsvoll.
Wohlgemerkt sind diese Antigen-Tests
derzeit noch nicht
zum Kauf erhältlich.
Die müssten erst
in großen Mengen produziert werden,
deswegen Hoffnung ist gut,
aber nicht vergessen:
Tests sind nur
eine Maßnahme von mehreren.
Jeder von uns trägt seinen Teil
zum Infektionsgeschehen bei,
sei es positiv oder negativ.
Während wir darauf warten,
dass Schnelltests vielleicht
bald Teil unseres Alltags werden,
haben wir, mit unserem
täglichen Verhalten,
immer noch das meiste
selbst in der Hand. Also:
Lasst uns keine Panik schieben,
aber auch bitte nicht verkacken.
(Entspannte Musik)
Wenn ihr das Video hilfreich fandet,
helft uns, die Infos zu verbreiten,
teilt das Video
mit Familie und Freunden.
Hier verlink ich euch ein Video
von meiner Funk-Kollegin Dr. Flojo.
Florence ist Ärztin und behandelt
auf ihrem Kanal medizinische Themen,
schaut da gerne mal vorbei.
Hier verlink ich euch noch 'n Video
von uns über Statistik,
und darüber, wie wir mit Zahlen
und Graphen manipuliert werden.
Wir sehn und in zwei Wochen,
bleibt sicher.